foreign
[Music]
hello
and welcome to building the Next
Generation game data platform using
firestore
my name is mid Nguyen and I am the
senior product management lead for
firestore
join with me today are also Martin
livsey director of software engineering
for 2K
and also Marcelo Pinero Staff Solutions
engineer at Google
we have an exciting session for you
today it will kick it off with a brief
overview of Firestorm followed with new
feature announcements
the highlight of the session will be a
fireside chat with 2K
we'll wrap it up with live questions and
answers from audience members like
yourself
let's get started
firestore's mission is to help you
unlock application Innovation with
simplicity
speed and confidence
we do this in three ways
the first
is through an Enterprise grade document
database
that offers flexible Json queryability
serializable acid-base transactions in a
distributed and sharded environment
and key Integrations with gcp's billing
monitoring and security tools
secondly firestore offers hands-free
scalability
you can elastically scale Firestar both
up and down with no intervention
firestore also offers
99.999
SLA backed availability guarantees
and this is managed through automatic
replication
and in the rare event that your replica
does go down there is zero data loss and
zero downtime
thirdly
firestore is focused on developer
ergonomics
to make you more productive
firestore is supported in over 17
languages in sdks
including back-end languages like Java
and client-side SDK languages like
JavaScript
firestore's client-side sdks offer
unique capabilities like real-time
synchronization and offline caching
and you can have the confidence that
when you adopt firestore you will be a
participant in a large developer
community
more importantly Firestar has over 5
million databases created today
and Firestar applications power over 1.3
billion monthly active end users using
Firebase off
we realize that your company's value is
within the products and services that
you offer
and that long application development
timelines hinder your ability to
maximize that value
so let's explore a little bit why
application development takes so long
what you see here is a common multi-tier
application architecture
you start with your database
then with your microservices
API gateways and then a number of UI
clients that access those back-end
services
each tier of that application
architecture requires operations that
includes availability so scalability and
security
with serverless products like firestore
you can delegate the operations of your
services to Google
now serverless Technologies tend to give
Enterprise customers the right balance
between customizability and efficiency
but on the firestore team we felt like
we could do a little bit more
one of the factors that plays into a
multi-tier architecture is the need to
hire for multiple specializations
and when you hire for this multiple
specializations you also have complex
project management across those
specializations which tends to slow
innovation
with this Insight in mind firestore
developed a mode of access in which we
call back-end as a service
and with back-end as a service your UI
clients can directly access firestore
in a secure manner
and when you bundle this with universal
application Frameworks like Unity or
with flutter
you can develop against a single code
base and deploy across all major
platforms including web mobile and
desktop
so the combination of firestore and
flutter
allows you to focus on hiring for a
single specialization
and with that team you can give that
team the autonomy to operate
that enables rapid innovation
so to summarize
flyer store is first and foremost a
Enterprise grade serverless document
database
but it also offers an optional mode of
access in which we call it back-end as a
service
okay this next section covers new
feature announcements
but before I begin I want to quickly
acknowledge the hardware that our
cross-functional team has been putting
in to make today possible thank you
firestore team
our future announcements today focus on
three major buckets
the first is developer productivity
the second is manageability
and the third is Unified data cloud
let's get started with developer
productivity
so we know that in developing Rich
applications you also need Rich query
functionality
and I'm excited to share today that we
are announcing a new set of query
aggregation functions
with sum and average you'll be able to
calculate aggregations across your
documents
we're also taking count to General
availability
and frequently you want to be able to
conduct queries across multiple fields
and multiple values
we're taking or and in to General
availability as well
okay
all the rages around Ai and ml
and you know with all the work that
we've been doing around pre-trained
models the access to large language
models has definitely been democratized
but there's still quite a bit of work in
regards to the last mile
how do you apply
that Ai and ml to your data
firestore is aiming to bridge that Gap
with our new text enrichment extensions
you'll be able to detect toxic hate
speech with a matter of a few clicks of
a button
similarly you'll be able to summarize
long-form texts
translate text in over 135 languages
and even transcribe audio
with media enrichment extensions you'll
be able to classify images
convert speech to text
and even perform optical character
recognition and store that in firestore
lastly
with our interactive AI extensions
you'll be able to utilize firestore and
popular services like vertex AI in order
to build your next chatbot
in addition to productivity we're also
focused on manageability
with multiple databases you'll be able
to create individual databases that are
isolated for security and performance
and you'll be able to monitor those
databases and view the bills of them
independently
with point in time recovery firestore
will Version Control your data and hold
on to that history within our online
storage system
we make that data directly queryable to
you
so that in the event of the human error
you can recover rapidly
and with scheduled backups firestore
will capture and retain your backups in
a cold storage system
another component of manageability is
observability
we've extended firestore's key
visualizer to help you identify indexing
hot spots
I'm also happy to share that firestore
is now available in over 27 locations
globally
okay we want to make it easier for you
to unify your data services
and with firestore's bigquery extensions
you'll be able to bi-directionally link
firestore and bigquery
let's say that you have a set of live
election results that are coming in and
being stored in bigquery but you really
need to serve those results to your end
users using firestore
with a few simple clicks you'll be able
to set up scheduled export jobs from
bigquery to firestore
and with our new event Arc triggers
you'll be able to subscribe to database
changes and to deliver those changes to
compute environments like gke
Cloud run
and Cloud functions
this is really great for use cases like
data replication
to use engines like full text search
okay this wraps up our new feature
announcements
I'd like to now invite Martin or Marcelo
on stage
Martin and Marcel will be conducting a
live fireside chat to reflect on 2k's
Journey on firestore
hello everybody
my name is Marcel opinero I introduce
myself first I'm a Staff Solutions
engineer here at Google
I work with the coolest Greatest Latest
Cutting Edge technology map on my back
at Google in the best customers that's a
great combination so marching why don't
you introduce yourself thanks very much
Marcelo so I'm Martin lipsey I'm a
director of software engineering inside
the core Technology Group uh at 2K
awesome so just to level set
expectations in the knowledge base here
why don't you talk us talk to us about
2k games in your role in your team what
do you what do you guys do there okay so
2K Games is a division of take two uh
we're one of the publishing labels of
take two we have a seven Studios that
produce many iconic games that you've
all seen loved played over the years NBA
is approaching its 25th year in
production uh you may have come across
titles like Civilization
XCOM
and Bioshock these are all 2K Games so
that's as part of 2K kind of like we
have a core Technology Group that
develops a online back end as a service
the database behind that is just one
piece of the tool set that we provide to
all of our Studios
awesome uh mentioned a phenomenal job
presenting the new features I'm super
excited about them all I'm not going to
give you a hard time pick one
which feature are you eager to adopt
which makes and why is that important
for you okay just one yep so of all of
the things that been talked about the
one that's most of interest to us is the
isolation of databases into different
things
right now how the system is implemented
we have one shared back-end database and
maybe some of you know something about
games when games go live the load that's
on them is incredibly spiky okay uh weak
inside the first couple of days we can
have uh 10 times or more load that we
would normally expect for steady state
under games so if I've got a back end as
a service that's supporting multiple
titles with a database
I'm going to have some nervous titles
that are already out there and being
used because they don't want the new
title to come in steal all the
performance at the back end so if I can
segregate out that data between
different databases then I have a bunch
of very happy Studios that feel
confident that we can launch our new
titles and their title isn't going to
get affected
awesome so avoiding the Noisy Neighbor
problem right very much so yes awesome
so let's
um Back to the Future kind of moment
looking back when we started talking can
you elaborate more on the uh what
problems we're trying to solve when you
approach at Google and why Google Cloud
was important of choice
so I initially heard about to kind of
like the idea behind open saves about
four years ago it was a nascent idea
inside Google at the time
and it was really just targeted at game
saves only nothing else and I I really
try to challenge Google to come up turn
the dial up to 11 guys let's see what
else we can develop here
and uh
kind of like take that bigger view of
kind of like what you can do with the
system so with that partnership we put
together a whole uh scale of kind of
like how can we store other data in
there so the kinds of data that we store
in a database now are like the loadouts
of characters uh configurations of the
online games such that if we're
operating and we want to change the
behavior of the game we can actually do
it in real time while the game is
running and then there is the initial
thing that we had as well which is all
of the game saves uh
why Google kind of like last I heard you
guys know a little bit about scaling
yeah that's fair one or two things yeah
where does 2k want to go scale scale
scale think about a title like NBA you
think about the scale that that title
goes to kind of like we need to be able
to onboard a title like that
instantaneously no issues so that's why
we partnered with Google
but we needed a performance and cost
effective solution as well so that's
what uh the the kind of like the system
that we're going to describe in the next
slide kind of like really allows us to
do
awesome so we talked about you know the
problems we're trying to solve open
saves Concepts let's talk a little bit
about how we build this together in any
conversation without an architecture
slide at least to me is not a
conversation to start with so let's put
a
sneak peek of the architecture's life
that's just a snapshot of one of the
backends I understand that there are
other components correct if I'm wrong
here yep use the gun is as the um game
Fleet Management Mark is there
uh uh open Match most with their
matchmaking systems all running on top
of gke right correct so I'll stop now
it's your talk can you walk us through
the architecture flow and how it works
absolutely so uh this is your generic
architecture slide for any online
service they all look the same
uh
on the right side is open saves so this
is the framework that we get to
firestore through
uh there's an in-memory layer for all of
our rapid access items then firestore is
the primary usage kind of this is where
all of the generalized unstructured
stuff goes primarily Json objects but
could be anything in there images
strings whatever and then the game saves
tend to end up in the kind of like the
large bulk storage area
so fronting there we have what we
internally built at 2K which we call
cloud data it's a Gateway and it adds in
kind of like extra stuff that we need to
be able to do so we need to know who
does this data belong to kind of like
which customers data is this which game
title is it serving is it uh kind of as
we'll talk about in a minute is it in is
it uh PGA is it midnight Sans data and
then finally kind of like we need some
kind of access permissions around these
things uh I don't want one game to be
able to read the data of another game so
we have a whole set of read write
permissions that allow you to kind of
like
[Applause]
keep keep the data segregated between
all of the titles and then on the front
of that there is the SDK that we use
internally at 2K to attach into all of
our games
yeah and I can see the global are you
done sorry yeah okay so the global load
balancer there that gives the global
Planet scale reach and scalability yeah
so all this is beautiful on these slides
great let's make sure that we
talk to the audience about what is
actually running on these things right
absolutely shall we talk about it yep
wrong button
so you may have heard of some of these
titles all of these came out within the
last few months all of these are
completely supported using the cloud
data open saves and firestore
architecture that we talked about so PGA
23 is the 2K golf game
all of the data around how the system
behaves and then as you're playing the
game how do my statistics accumulate uh
between all of the swings that they take
all of the shots they make in the golf
game they're all stored in this online
back end
Marvel midnight Suns has a completely
different usage pattern because it's
it's a very different kind of game but
similarly they store small unstructured
data for many different things but then
they also have large game saves that
they store several megabytes at a time
that is built into the back end it's
great because we can we don't have to
change anything the game team can just
throw things in there it goes in the
right place and then the most recent
title that really is using all of the
capabilities as a system is Lego 2K
drive it's got everything in there we
store configuration files for the title
such as I mentioned you can change the
behavior of the game on the Fly the
client picks it up and it's all stored
in one place in the database
that's awesome
so can I conclude that you have some
experience launching games a little bit
we might have launched one or two okay
let's talk about gaming launch
experience yeah right uh you've launched
those games using Google Cloud can you
talk us a bit about the experience using
firestore you must have a big team
we actually have a very small team
powerful there thank you uh you kind of
like the internal team that developed
the cloud data platform the Gateway is
only two people
so it's small so if you didn't have a
serverless firestore backhand with low
Ops you know we we wouldn't be doing it
okay yeah let me go back to the question
then uh launching games you know talk
about the experience of launching games
with Google Cloud how the firestore team
help uh how the your account team help
launch those games yeah so I'll I'll
kind of like talk about the PGA title
because this was the first launch of a
game using brand new technology
people are always nervous launching a
new game when there hasn't been another
game shipped on it before they're
worried about is it going to work you
can do all the testing in the universe
that you want to do but no one's
confident until it's actually out there
supporting it we had a minor hiccup
guess what Utah new technology things
always work perfectly first time right
maybe not we had a little bit of a
hiccup but the Google team was there for
us they were there they had 24 hour
rotation to the first two weeks along
with us to make sure that when there
were any issues that we could pick these
up and we could actually do something
with it awesome what I like about this
example is like uh in this case
particularly
one of the features that mean presented
the key visualize everything vaccine
that was key
to solve to identify the hot spotting
yeah so
we had the issue we couldn't work it out
Google opened up their box of tricks and
this the kind of like the key visualizer
wasn't even in uh
pre-production yeah you kind of like
said hey we've got a new tool it's
coming it's not live yet
as kind of like uh you know the one of
the partners that we're working with
we're going to take it out of the box
now and use it and it was exactly the
tool that we needed to sort out the
minor haircut we had an index clash and
the visualizer picked it up straight
away solved the issue we were done and
dusted in a couple of days awesome
um and just going back to the uh
launch experience uh we have a very
robust process as Martin was describing
a little bit of it and our goal we
strive to make gaming launch gaming game
launches as boring as possible
and at the end of the launch someone
sends the meme of this Lounge could have
been an email that's the goal so if you
have that that's the cheaper goal right
yep so
midnight Suns Lego 2K drive from an open
saves and a cloud data perspective
completely boring you can have no issues
whatsoever very happy internal teams
that their games launched at scale kind
of like out of the box that's awesome uh
we talked about Back to the Future I'm
gonna put a crystal ball right here now
look into the future what does the
future look like for you
uh
maybe just maybe we might be making some
more games can like you never know I
can't talk about what they might be yet
maybe you can guess some of them
so all of this technology is going to go
into pretty much every new game that 2K
is building over time
uh
and then that kind of Gateway that I
talked about earlier the the cloud data
Gateway that we constructed to kind of
like build on top of open saves our
intent is to also open source all of
that technology as well uh we're gonna
kind of like d2kfi it so it's very
generic but that's our goal is to open
source that technology
awesome
um thanks again for the years of strong
collaboration partnership likewise
thanks to you and your team the whole 2K
team I'd like to thank also my team my
the whole support team from Google
they're there
thanks for all the help
[Applause]
[Music]